Moment moment moment
informationen sollen ein fahrzeug eintreiben soll das bitte funktionieren
die antwort quanten thermodynamik und stand eines tanks oder einer batterie gibt es einen
informationsspeicher und den füllt man auch in dem man die während der fahrt geschriebene informationen mit hilfe von elektrischer energie wieder löscht
bot ja das video übrigens in zusammenarbeit mit technology review entstanden und am ende bekommt ihr einen gratis heft der wirklich hammer
zeitschrift geschenkt nicht um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Von der thermodynamik quasi der klassische schwester der quanten thermodynamik habt ihr sicher schon mal das ein oder andere mal im physikunterricht gehört im
neunzehnten jahrhundert waren die menschen endlich in der lage sich durch die erfindung der dampfmaschinen und lokomotiven schneller fortzubewegen
als mit pferdestärke die prozesse in diesen maschinen wurden dann von verschiedenen forscherinnen und forschern genauer untersucht und in den so genannten
haupt setzen der
thermodynamik auch schriftlich festgehalten energie in einem system kann sich nur dann ändern wenn
arbeit oder wärme zu oder abgeführt werden so der erste satz wärme kann nicht von einem körper von
niedriger temperatur auf einen körper von höherer temperatur übergehen so der zweite satz dazu gibt es seit
1865 die abstrakte größe der sogenannten
entropie das maß für unordnung es kann nur größer werden oder aber gleich bleiben übertragen auf alle wärmekraft maschinen wie etwa
verbrennungsmotoren bedeutet das dass sie eben nur einen bestimmten
maximalen effizienz grad erreichen können in der fachsprache wird dies als carnot
wirkungsgrad bezeichnet diesen ganzen regeln und setzten zufolge ist ein perpetuum
mobile also nicht möglich nichts kann aus mechanischer arbeit wärme erzeugen oder aus wärme mechanische arbeit und sich so unendlich
weiter bewegen doch diese standard regeln der thermodynamik gelten nicht in der alltagswelt der moleküle und atome
zumindest sind einige forschungsdienst davon überzeugt unter anderem tobias schätz von der universität freiburg zitat der quanten
hält sich nicht an die regeln der thermodynamik und er hat ein eigenes beispiel dazu konzipiert einen
mikroskopisch kleinen kristall er besteht aus fünf ionen in einer elektromagnetischen
falle ein angeregtes ion gibt seine energie als schwingung an den kristall ab und fühlt sich somit ab normalerweise
würde sich diese schwingung quasi totlaufen doch nicht in solch kleinen
dimensionen hier
wirft das ende des kristalls die schwingung zurück und der sion wird wieder angeregt die wärme kehrt hier also wieder zu ihrem ursprung zurück und
fließt nicht ab das ganze kann man auch als nano kühlung bezeichnen und schon
2016 hatte ein
forschungsteam aus mainz eine solche wärme kraft maschine gebaut und zwar die kleinste der welt sie besteht aus einem einzelnen kalium ionen
eingesperrt in einem elektrischen wechselfeld das dazu führt dass es sich nur in
eine richtung bewegen kann quasi wie ein kolben in einem zylinder
elektrisches rauschen heizte das ion an
laserstrahlen kühlt es dann wieder ab das diente als antrieb vorstellbar also ein ein auto mega kühlschrank mit dem sich
nanoelektronik kühlen ließe falls man diesen kreis prozess der seo motors umkehren könnte das große ziel der
theoretischen physikerinnen und physiker den wirkungsgrad solcher atom maschinen über das thermodynamische
limit zu erhöhen also dass kano limit überschreiten dazu könnte die heisenbergsche unschärferelation
dienen nach der sich impuls und ort eines zeichens nicht gleichzeitig ganz genau bestimmen lassen um dies umzusetzen
müsste man den ort des atoms sehr exakt bestimmen sodass sein impuls um bestimmt wird dies führe wiederum zu
fluktuation die dem atom die benötigten kräfte verleihen um das kann ohne mit zu überschreiten doch es gibt auch kritiker den diese idee bezweifeln
beispielsweise der vierziger renato renner von der eth zürich
dass man auf diese weise den zweiten hauptsatz um geben könnte ist eine illusion um den wirkungsgrad über das thermodynamische
erlaubte zu steigern müsste man also immer wissen welche
auswirkung die fluktuation hat und nur im positiven fall den motor betreiben soll es liegt im wesen einer fluktuation dass sie eben nicht
vorhersagbar ist seiner meinung nach dann eben nicht nur fluktuationen die den wirkungsgrad erhöhen sondern auch welche die ihn senken doch renner
ist der quanten thermodynamik nicht ganz abgeneigt und erinnert an ein gedankenexperiment von
1871 hier sitzt einen dämon an einer klappe zwischen zwei luft gefüllten behältern und hat die aufgabe diese klappe zu öffnen und zu schließen
dies führt dazu dass sich letztendlich in dem einen behälter die schnellen moleküle und in dem anderen die langsam befinden sprich
warm schnell
langsamkeit dazu muss keine energie aufgewendet werden solange die klappe reibungsfrei gelagert ist die moleküle sind also
geordnet und somit ist die entropie gesunken verbotenerweise
somit ließe sich mit der differenz der temperatur eine wärme
kraftmaschine betreiben und zwar eine die ewig läuft die lösung für dieses paradoxon liegt wohl im gehirn des dämons das hatte ein
forschungsteam in den 80er jahren herausgefunden denn er muss alle moleküle
und deren
geschwindigkeiten sehen sie auf die klappe zu kommen um diese korrekt zu bedienen doch auch sein gehirn ist irgendwann voll da alle informationen
abgespeichert werden müssen heisst also diese infos muss man löschen um das spiel weiter zu spielen dazu renner
durch dieses löschen muss gemäss dem zweiten hauptsatz soviel entropie entstehen dass die gesamtbilanz größer als null wird das ganze
konnte vor einem jahr 2017 auch in einem experiment belegt werden ein
supraleitender ring verstärkte einen mikrowellen puls immer weiter das entspricht dem immer wärmer werdenden behälter das gedankenexperiment
doch die bedingung dass dies funktionierte die
informationen über den quantenzustand des rings in einem mikrowellen resonators dem dämon mussten erst gespeichert
und dann auch wieder gelöscht werden also so kann das ganze tatsächlich
funktionieren das experiment zeigte eben dass alle hauptsätze der thermodynamik erfüllt waren denn für das löschen der information brauchte es dann energie
aufgewendet werden muss das fazit also
auch wenn die idee mit dem motor als festplatte erst einmal verrückt klingt sie könnte vielleicht realität werden zumindest im mikrokosmos
ja vielen dank an technology review in zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion
dieser richtigen hammer zeit ist dieses ja ich finde mind blowing video entstanden und exklusiver blick zum zuschauer habe ich jetzt ein geschenk
bekommt nämlich eine ausgabe gratis wenn ihr auf diesen link hier oben klickt das lohnt sich richtig
da sind noch mehr coole themen drin und ich darunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken neuer
revolutionärer raumfahrt antrieb bis dann
bleibt dran